big breaking developments surrounding
the investigation into FISA abuse
tonight including new information about
the dirty days author Christopher Steele
we also bring you some good news for
Lieutenant General Michael Flynn and his
battle against the witch hunt which
continues first we start with Bob Muller
next Wednesday the captain of the
witch-hunt himself while he's scheduled
to appear before Congress in his first
and only public hearing Democrats on the
house Intel and judiciary committees are
demanding that Muller testify well
according to our own Chad program well
he's saying these very same Democrats
and now worried that their political
stunt is about to backfire and boomerang
Wow that's happened a lot and for good
reason and there's only public comments
a rambling contradictory nine minute
presser well Robert Muller well he
stated that he would not expand on any
of his findings he said that the written
report it will be his only testimony
we're talking about the very same report
that cleared the president of collusion
conspiracy with Russia and didn't charge
him with any obstruction and by the way
he was not charged with obstruction
because the Attorney General Deputy
Attorney General Office of Legal Counsel
all said nope didn't happen meanwhile
Muller is certainly going to face very
crucial questions from Republicans
questions I'd like to have answered
we're going to preview those important
questions in a minute but this now comes
as a report is now out that the DOJ is
blocking House Democrats from
questioning two members of moas partisan
team and a closed-door hearing here with
more as our own Chad program was with us
Chad what's the latest well there was a
hearing tonight a meeting tonight by
Democrats on the House Judiciary
Committee trying to figure out the
structure of this hearing with Bob
Muller next week now Sean there's an old
saying on Capitol Hill that nothing is
decided until everything is decided what
we do know is that there's going to be a
two-hour hearing for members of the
Judiciary Committee starting at nine
o'clock there will be a break and then
they'll come back two hours later with
members of the Intelligence Committee
the question is is that enough time and
it was very interesting to see members
coming out of this closed-door meeting
saying that everything is in flux that
things haven't been decided yet we were
told by multiple members these are
Democrats that they are still
negotiating with Bob molars team of
the structure of this members really
didn't want to talk as they came out
they were deferring to Jerry Nadler the
chair of the Judiciary Committee and
many leukorrhea who's a Democrat from
California also Pramila jeyapaul who's a
Democrat from Washington State both of
them said that some of this may not be
resolved until the day of the hearing
Debbie Mook arsal Pao is a freshman
Democrat from Florida you know if you
cut this down to just two hours in two
hours there's some question as to
whether or not the freshman members of
the more junior members would get a
chance to ask ask questions we asked
Mook our soul pal that she said well I
hope so
the other thing that's still up in the
air in the air here Sean Orr is if there
would be a closed-door session Erick's
wha well who's a member from California
also a member of the Intelligence
Committee he said well I hope so
the problem for Democrats here is if
Mahler just sticks to the report the
four corners of the report and doesn't
go beyond that have Democrats overplayed
this you know there's another expression
up here a caveat emptor buyer beware
maybe this turns out to be pretty boring
if robert muller is just going through
dog-eared pages and reading back when
he's getting questions there could that
undermine the hype in some in some ways
and that's where some of us here at fox
who've done reporting on this have heard
that you know Muller might be a little
bit reluctant to testify or there might
be an effort to limit or curtail his
testimony Sean but we are told that he
is on for nine o'clock next Wednesday
morning
all right chance in Washington will be
watching the next Thursday now let's be
clear Bob Muller well he's not a king he
was employed by we the American people
the American people also deserve answers
to other questions for a few questions I
think Mullen must answer why did he hire
a team with no Republicans only big
Democratic donors why did he hire
Hillary Clinton's former attorney why
did he hire the guy oh yes Sidney Powell
exposed in license to lie the ever so
overzealous prosecutor Muller's pit bull
Andrew Weissman to lead the
investigation after all Weissman he was
at Clinton's election night party that
never happened likely solving with
everybody else there he also has this
atrocious track record withholding
exculpatory evidence numerous cases that
are overturned convictions overturned
because of exculpatory evidence withheld
and also why did Muller have time to
investigate let's see taxi medallions
loan applications fara violations and
tax fraud but not FISA abuse and not a
paid for Russian dossier if he cared
about Russian interference and the in
the 2016 elections why then does he not
have any probe into Hillary Clinton's
dirty dossier the one with Russian lies
the one that was disseminated to the
American people to influence the
election now where was the deep dive
into the ex foreign spy Christopher
Steele
what about fusion GPS their connections
to unsavory characters around the world
and their founder Glenn Simpson when did
Muller determined that there was no
Trump Russia collusion why didn't he
stop then why did the investigation
continue after that determination and
why did Muller contradict himself during
his nine and a half minute press
conference now remember the special
counsel first claimed there was no
obstruction he said that to numerous
people then at the presser he suggested
there might have been obstruction but a
sitting president cannot be charged
because the DOJ policy now that was when
he released a joint statement with the
Attorney General bars office stating
that while there was no chargeable
obstruction regardless of DOJ policy and
the ability to charge a sitting
president
so why the confusion why the change who
wrote those words who wrote the report
were you being told what to say by
Andrew Weissman your pit bull because
the whole witch-hunt was a disaster from
beginning to end a major distraction
from real abuses of power taking place
right under your nose just look at the
fraud that took place around in the FISA
warrant your buddy Jim Comey signed it
the first one against the Trump can't
pay an associate Carter page and that
gave them a backdoor to spy into all
things Trump campaign then Trump
transition then the Trump presidency and
as the Daily Caller points out the
bureau's desperate attempts to acquire a
warrant were totally stalled until
Steel's dossier came along
deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe said
it perfectly
no dossier no FISA warrant and call me
in company it was so desperate to find
that
backdoor into the Trump campaign yes mr.
Comey to spy that they use phony what we
now know to be unverifiable campaign
Clinton bought and paid for op research
full of Russian lies and that was to
obtain an a warrant to spy on an
American citizen and an entire
presidential campaign and according to
the New York Times investigators working
for the IG s probe into FISA abuse well
they asked Christopher Steele quote
whether the bureau was overly reliant on
the Russian expertise of outsiders like
himself and still told him them that he
believed the FBI was probably under
equipped to judge the inherently murky
intelligence that he was relaying I
don't believe that's true either and The
Times was also reporting that one of
steel' sources quote added his own
interpretations to reports from his own
sources that he passed on to steal
calling into question the reliability of
all of this information and by the way
they were all warned about it before the
first FISA warrant was signed by call me
in October 2016 the one that he swore
swore was verified and true the one
three months later in January of 2017
told President Trump is unverified in
salacious in other words the so-called
intelligence in the dossier was sourced
with second third hand information all
turned out to be false and perhaps just
completely made-up or maybe as the New
York Times previously suggested it was
Russian misinformation all along but
call me others swore that their
intelligence was true and accurate that
is fraud plain and simple premeditated
conspiracy to commit fraud on a FISA
Court to spy on an opposition party
candidate to help one campaign win and
the other campaign lose and then it
became an insurance policy as we all
learned while months later
but despite high-ranking government
officials turning the most powerful
tools of intelligence that we need to
keep us safe against enemies foreign and
domestic
well they turned them on the Trump
campaign and other American citizens and
the transition team and on the Trump
presidency we have forced separate
Russia collusion investigations all for
cleared the president of any wrongdoing
there's no more am big
there's no questions to ask anymore
House Democrats they're now conducting
what is the fifth and sixth
investigation into collusion so-called
collusion that didn't happen
the only collusion that happened was
Hillary Clinton's dirty dossier
that's how Democrats are spending your
tax dollars this is nothing more at this
point than presidential harassment and
an abuse of power by them people like
Nadler and the cowardly shift leading
these brand-new probes wasting the
country's time and they're now having
innocent American citizens that have to
once again lawyer up they're going
bankrupt in some cases as they are
called to answer the same questions for
a fourth fifth and sixth time and by the
way every time they answer they better
answer it perfectly the way they did the
last time or else they'll determine that
that's perjury then they'll get charged
with that and they'll need more lawyers
my advice to all of those people that
willingly testified to Congress that
cooperated with the Muller probe you
know you can plead the fifth and you
know what it won't cost you a dime you
don't have to hire any more lawyers and
you can stand up to this abuse of power
Nadler and shift they're no longer
lawmakers this is an oversight this is
now them merely can't content creators
for well oh yeah MS DNC and Roswell
Rachel Maddow is non-stop anti Trump
conspiracy hours it's one every second
every minute every hour of every day
over there at MSD NCE Democrats well
they should what they're doing should
sick and every American